I'm Jules Jaffe I am a research
scientist at the Scripps Institution of
Oceanography part of the University of
California San Diego I started my career
being recruited by the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution and that
resulted in in helping to build the Argo
system that actually found the Titanic
as a research scientist I am asked by
the University to think of interesting
subjects that would result in
exploration and discovery of science in
the ocean
the mau ii which were named because
they're miniature autonomous explorers
is in very layman's terms a float that
one places in the sea and tracks its
three-dimensional trajectory over the
last five to six years we've done a
number of experiments to use these
miniature floats to study how currents
push things around so we would typically
put them in for a couple of afternoons
we would get a lot of data we would
analyze their trajectories and we've
learned a lot of interesting things
about plankton and how they're pushed
around the thing that I'm really excited
about related to the future of this
technology is multi-dimensional first of
all even though we're fascinated with
outer space we know very little about
the submerged part of our own planet and
and the ocean plays a huge role in
global ecology half of the oxygen we
breathe is produced by little
photosynthetic creatures in the ocean so
the first thing that gets me excited
about this technology is the act of
learning things that we hadn't known
before so that's the first thing the
second thing that gets me excited about
this technology is the revolution that's
happening in accessibility so what we're
seeing today is what I think is referred
to as a maker generation so so we can
actually now three dimensionally print
components of all kinds of things
including underwater vehicles there's
one example and build these for a
fraction of what they would have cost as
recent as ten years so it's this sort of
combination
of unknown and the hyperbolic increase
in accessibility is what gets me really
really excited
these miniature vehicles are not very
expensive and they can tell us so much
about what's going on in the sea there
are a number of projects now to increase
the density of miniature vehicles that
would allow us to have better sampling
so imagine you have a chemical that goes
down and then we sample it here and here
well we didn't really know where it
stopped so if we could have multiple
samples at higher densities we could
understand where it was but if we can
then track that in time then we could
see the dynamics of it and the physics
of it so there is a initiative in the US
now to look at even building 50,000
vehicles that can go into the sea and
there really is no limit to the
knowledge that we would obtain with with
the right sensors and having swarms of
underwater vehicle we want to make them
smaller I have a little egg on my desk
which is a an old toy which in the
States was called silly putty and it's
about the size of an egg and and it
reminds me that I want to build a robot
that is that big what a fascination
there is with exploring these micro
worlds as an inhabitant not as an
observer
this robotic technology the maker
generation and the future of underwater
miniature robots I like to think of
myself as the father maybe I'm more like
the grandfather of this technology and
and I think of it as something that I'm
really proud of that I could usher this
new generation subscribe to the Science
Museum's channel to discover more
fascinating science stories